Do you work with any oncologists that understand cancer like I do?
I don't know if I understand cancer at all.
But certainly we don't work with any oncologists that think the way we do.
And the reason is quite simple. It's because they can't.
So if they do think like I do, then they can't voice that opinion.
So unless they just leave the practice of medicine and practice under, you know,
you know, the same thing that I did and have to practice under a pastoral medical license or something like that because they, they would lose their license.
So understand we get the Minnesota Medical Board coming after us right now because they're saying I'm practicing medicine without a license.
So this is just this is just the fight that that you deal with when you go against the pharmaceutical companies.
They just don't like people like me and they will fight people like me.
And certainly you cannot be a practitioner of colleges to think alternatively.
I don't actually know a doctor right now that I know this doctor personally, she practices in emergency medicine and she had a stage 4 cancer patient come into the ER.
And this person was very overweight and explained she asked what what's going on and she the person was having a lot of symptoms. I think gut symptoms.
This person was explaining what they eat. And the doctor said, well, maybe if you got cancer, you got to start thinking that maybe you shouldn't be eaten cake adults.
Other practicing physician that I think was it rounds with her learning from her, heard that she said, if you have cancer, maybe you better stop, you better stop eating cake adults reported her to the Minnesota Medical Association.
And she's under investigation now for recommending that the stage 4 cancer patient not eat cake adults.
This is where we've come folks. So this is just what we deal with.